bonjour bienvenue dans le meilleur de
ses caches aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'europe face à la crise du
coc vide
l'union européenne est une chimère elle
n'existe pas et d'ailleurs vous avez on
peut pas le qualifier honnêtement
d'euros fob vous avez même monsieur le
maire qui a dit que si on continuait
comme ça c'était la fin de l'union
européenne et donc c'est pas moi qu'il
dit là pour une fois c'est c'est des
gens qui sont plutôt dans le moule est
bien bien europhile donc on a vu qu
secte est totalement inefficace on a vu
que chacun joué sa carte on a vu que il
n'y avait absolument pas de coordination
dit sur la fermeture des frontières ni
sur le confinement ni sur quoi que ce
soit ni sur les masques qu'on s'amuse à
se piquer les uns les autres off avant
on est dans quelque chose qui n'a rien à
voir avec une union quelconque
alors justement olivier en matière de
politique de santé lieu de vous laver
des ans disposent de faibles marges de
manoeuvre aussi puisque la santé ne fait
pas partie de ses prérogatives selon le
traité de fonctionnement de lieux
l'union encourage la coopération et
complète les politiques nationales
ce qui veut dire qu'elle les états
gardent donc ait la main-mise sur leur
politique de santé est ce qu'il faudrait
peut-être revoir un peu hâlé statut
d'abord il faudrait que il faudrait que
les états aient réellement la main en ce
qui concerne de la france
montrez moi la main parce que pour
l'instant je la vois pas beaucoup en
allemagne
ils ont réussi à tester tout le monde
ils ont réussi à distribuer des masques
à tout le monde nous on en est encore à
attendre des masques et attendre des
distributions de test donc pour le coup
on n'a vraiment pas la main en france et
en italie
c'est quasi pareil donc les deux les
deux pays
on peut pas dire ont failli complètement
sur leur gestion de crise et l'europe
n'a rien à voir là dedans alors oui en
effet sur les les différentes mesures
qu'on n'a que monsieur le maire a
arraché la deuxième réunion de l'euro
vous avez eu 2 % qui vont être attribués
à la halle à à la santé sans
contrepartie pour le n est pas bon ça
arrive à la fin et on peut pas dire que
ce soit quelque chose qui va changer la
face de cette de cette crise qui n'est
pas je vous rappelle qu'une crise de
santé publique c'est c'est
malheureusement devenu une crise
économique majeure
alors on l'était avant de passer au
volet économique un concrètement un mot
juste sur ce sondage en italie et selon
à une étude de moniteurs italia qui a
été publié le 13 mars dernier
90 % des italiens estiment que l'ue ne
les aide pas face au co vie de 10 9 67%
considèrent qu appartenir à l'union
constitue un désavantage
est ce que cette crise actuelle qui est
lié
donc à l'épidémie de coronavirus
pourrait remettre sur la table l'envi
pour certains pays de quitter le navire
mais toute façon je vous le dis depuis
longtemps dans cette émission que
l'italie finira par sortir parce que
c'est invivable
mais tout le monde maintenant le dit
c'est ça qui est qui est extraordinaire
même les gens qui l'ont créé cet euro
comme jacques attali jacques attali dans
un dans une conférence dernièrement a
dit que l'euro était quelque chose qui
était mal montée qui ne marcherait
jamais et qui éclaterait parce que c'est
c'est mal monté mais qu' il avait tout
fait aussi pour pourrir la vie des gens
qui qui voudraient en sortir donc on
sait très bien que c'est ses pattes
nabeul cette histoire et les crises le
montre pourquoi ça a fonctionné entre
2000 et 2008 parce qu'il se passait rien
parce que tout allait bien et puis tout
d'un coup en 2008 patatrac une récession
et une première crise de l'euro en 2011
qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment là on
voit que les fondations ont été mal fait
ou on a dû en accueillir toutes
fondation on a quand même fait des
chaînes de solidarité ou l'allemagne par
exemple a pris en charge certains
patients français
il ya quand même une chaîne de
solidarité qui se fait même s'ils
veulent vous l'a prié objectif c'est pas
parce que vous avez un hôpital à la
frontière qui prend 3
infectés du corps en un virus français
qu' il faut saluer le l'europe l'union
européenne et l'euro soyons sérieux je
veux dire il n'y a rien qui a été fait
tout le monde a tiré dans son coin et cc
on s'est aperçu tout sauf à je veux dire
maintenant il n'ya pas il ya même plus
de débat on sait que l'union européenne
est morte on sait que les italiens n'en
peuvent plus et qu' ils vont prendre le
premier prétexte qu'ils auront dans les
24 mois qui vont suivre le le le le pic
de la crise ils sortiront et à ce moment
là vous n'aurez plus d'union européenne
et vous n'aurez plus d'euros tout
simplement parce que c'est là c'est le
troisième pays cette zone économique et
que jamais on ne pourra continuer avec
avec l'italie en moins donc je pense que
le le le sujet et est bien réglé
manifestement les gouvernements
européens ne parviennent pas à se mettre
d'accord pour mener ce travail a bien
donc on retombe dans un contexte de
concots n'est bien qui a marqué tout
près toutes les années de la présidence
de mario draghi où finalement il n'y a
pas de commandant ou de capitaines de
navire à la tête de la zone euro à part
la banque centrale européenne ce qui
conduit effectivement à faire tout à
faire reposer un quasi intégralité des
mesures économiques et la politique des
initiatives de sauvetage sur le dos
d'une banque centrale
olivier est ce que vous diriez vous
aussi peut-être que la banque centrale
européenne et donc christine lagarde ont
pris la mesure de la gravité de la
situation un peu tardivement
elle est surtout totalement incompétente
au poste où elle et elle était déjà
incompétente au fmi je vois pas pourquoi
son transfert à la bce l'aurait rendu
compétents donc change la vie exactement
comme note
d'ailleurs comme notre président change
d'avis toutes les tous les deux jours et
donc rien ne rien ne m'étonne ski ski ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire
aujourd'hui et toutes les banques
centrales
c'est ce que je vous dis depuis très
longtemps c'est à dire le jour où il ya
un pépin c'est c'est du all in c'est à
dire on met ce que ce qu'il faut sur la
table pour que pour empêcher surtout les
les marchés de de baisser donc ils y
vont je dirais presque à la à la
japonaise c'est c'est une japonisation
des banques centrales qui se mettre à
acheter tout et n'importe quoi la
dernière déclaration de madame lagarde
c'est que elle achètera des giants
bon ben voila quand on en est à ce
niveau là si vous voulez c'est que on
est capable comme comme monsieur draghi
l'avait fait en 2000 ou dans 2012
c'était je ferai tout ce qu'il faut pour
pour que l'euro ne ne sont pas on est en
train de faire exactement la même chose
en plus gros parce que la situation
demande qui est plus de d'argent qu'ils
soient déversés alors si vous voulez
bien on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet
on va détailler les mesures qui ont été
prises par la banque centrale européenne
ces dernières semaines avec d'abord un
crédit aux entreprises auto de -0 75%
100 milliards d'euros de liquidités aux
banques
l'achat de 120 milliards d'obligations
le rachat de 750 milliards de dettes
publiques et privées la possibilité de
rachat de junk bond si vous en avez
parlé olivier donc des obligations mal
notés comme la dette grecque ou encore
la dette italienne
et puis la clause du grand-père pour les
obligations en dégradation
la banque centrale européenne a donc
annoncé un programme d'achat l'urgence
pandémique hauteur donc de 750 milliards
d'euros
l'un des aspects les plus notables de ce
programme c'est le fait que la banque
centrale européenne s'autorise désormais
à acheter les obligations de la grèce
mais aussi de s'écarter temporairement
de la khl
de capital c'est à dire que la banque
centrale européenne peut concentrer ses
interventions sur un pays en particulier
on pense notamment à l'italie véronique
riches florès est ce que vous direz que
c'est une bonne chose une bonne piste
qu'est ce que vous pensez plus
globalement de ces mesures prises par la
bce alors deux choses je pense
qu'effectivement si les politiques de
banques centrales sont très critiquables
et c'est la critique a adressé par
olivier sur ce qui se passe ces
dernières années cite également parce
qu'on a laissé se développer une sphère
financière qu'ils occupent dans nos
économies et à l'échelle mondiale
d'ailleurs les proportions comme on a
quasiment probablement jamais vu dans
l'histoire et qu'à partir de là
effectivement tout risque de correction
des marchés un tant soit peu
significatif conduit à des opérations de
sauvetage proportionnelle c'est
probablement ce qui explique l'ampleur
des décisions prises revenons sur la bce
madame lagarde a fait une énorme erreur
au début la sous-estimation des effets
de la crise étaient très très choquant
d'ailleurs et finalement elle n'a pas
tenu trois jours avant de devoir changer
son fusil d'épaulé temps les
conséquences ont été désastreuses sur
les marchés financiers et notamment sur
la dette souveraine des pays et en
particulier d'italie donc on prend des
mesures alors en terme de ce qui est ce
qui me semble important
ça fait des années qu'on dit qu'il faut
qu'il faudrait se séparer de cette clé
de répartition du capital pour pouvoir
intervenir de manière beaucoup plus
efficace ce qu'on a ce qui s'est passé
effectivement c'est que les allemands et
la plupart des pays du nord mais
particulièrement les allemands ont
d'exiger effectivement le respect de
cette paix de capital pour pour
contrôler la l'équité entre guillemets
des opérations de la bce sur les marchés
ce qui a conduit à cette situation
absurde où bien évidemment
le pays le plus important étant
l'allemagne
la bce a surtout acheter des obligations
de l'allemagne au point de pressuriser
le niveau des taux d'intérêt allemands
de jusqu'en territoire très fortement
négatif et est d'affaiblir
considérablement le système bancaire
allemand
donc au lieu de concentrer tous les
efforts parce qu'elle quand même eu
beaucoup de programmes d'intervention de
la bce au fil des années tous les
efforts sur les pays sur lesquels on
avait de vrais risques voire des risques
d'ailleurs systémique et on pense à la
grèce on pense à l'italie ce qui aurait
été beaucoup plus efficace qui
permettrait également de se présenter
comme l'institution qui intervient là où
il ya des risques là où il le faut et
qui est à 2 fait d'une force de frappe
beaucoup plus importante et bien on
dissémine des actions sur en fonction
d'une plaie capital donc au prorata des
pipes des différents pays c'était
absurde
il est important je pense que le fait de
se libérer de cette contrainte rend plus
crédible le la façon dont la bce
intervient reste à savoir et c'est loin
d'être claires mais jusqu'à présent et
semble néanmoins que à la fin de l'année
là les interventions de la bce doivent
bien néanmoins correspondre à cette
répartition du capital donc on gagne en
flexibilité au niveau des interventions
ponctuelles en pouvant potentiellement
racheté plus de dette italienne s'il ya
des tensions et si la nécessité s'en
fait ressentir que de la dette allemande
mais probablement qu'à la fin de l'année
il faudra rééquilibrer tension donc
enfin on va vers quelque chose qui est
un petit peu puissant c'est me
semble-t-il mais qui est encore loin
d'être tout à fait satisfaisant
que je pense c'est que c'est que en fait
tous les verrous vont sauter les uns
après les autres on est en train de voir
ça c'est à dire le verrou de la
répartition ensuite il y avait un
deuxième verrou qui était que les
banques centrales n'agissaient pas sur
sur des john bantz maintenant c'est fait
vous avez
vous aurez aussi des verrous qui vont
sauter sur les marchés actions sur les
au tf
exactement je vous dis c'est une
japonisation de toutes les banques
centrales de mario draghi la relance
voilà on aboutira à la même chose
c'est-à-dire que ils rachèteront
directement les dettes émises par les
par les états et que vous aurez petit à
petit le même on est en train de prêtres
de prendre de toute façon le même le
même chemin on a des démographie en
berne
on a des taux de d'endettement par
rapport au pib qui maintenant vont
dépasser dans tous les pays largement
les 100 % quand c'est pas 150 voire
quelquefois de sens donc on est on est
en train de ce japonais est réellement
et et bat regarder ce qui se passe
depuis déjà plusieurs années au japon à
chaque fois que les taux d'intérêt
remontent au dessus de zéro va parler
déjà mondialement superbe arrêt mission
al masri pas pour les remettre en
dessous de zéro
ils achètent tous les au tf qui qui qui
sortent ils achètent des actions
directement ils achètent des indices pas
on a cessé du cdu l'open bar c'est ce
que je disais dans le monde dans mon
introduction c'est de l'open bar donc
ils mettront tout ce qu'il faudra sur la
table parce que aujourd'hui véronique
l'a dit à à l'instant vous êtes dans une
logique où les banques centrales ne sont
plus data dépendantes
c'est à dire qu'elles ne font n
n'anticipe plus rien par rapport à
l'économie réelle mais elles sont
devenues marque est dépendante depuis
une dizaine d'années et aujourd'hui
elles doivent absolument tenir le marché
financier parce que vous avez des fonds
de pension qui sont bourrés de risques
vous avez des banques qui sont pleines
d'obligations plus ou moins pourri parce
que vous avez tout un système financier
qui est maintenant le coeur du système
économique puisque tout marche sur la
bête est donc vous
des banques centrales qui sont devenus
complètement marque est dépendante et la
seule chose qui va les faire bouger dans
un sens ou dans un autre
sont les marchés financiers et c'est pas
autre chose c'est pas les données
économiques qu'ils ont justement les
démarches à nice et on va jeter un coup
d'oeil sur la courbe du cac 40 de ces
dernières semaines il semblerait qu'il y
ait eu un impact quand même des mesures
annoncées par la banque centrale
européenne mais pas seulement évidemment
véronique riches florès la question j'ai
envie de vous poser c'est est-ce que
effectivement ces mesures ont eu un
impact concret sur les marchés en
quelques mots jusqu'où peut aller la
banque centrale européenne alors oui
pour avoir eu un impact sur les marchés
elles sont bien impactés incontestable
qui a fait rebondir les marchés des
finalement le 23 mars ans je crois que
c'est à peu près le point bas sur la
plupart des indices et c'est intéressant
parce que cette date finalement marque
le début de la période de confinement
quasi généralisée en tout cas croissante
c'est à dire le début du du choc
économique liés à cette épidémie et et
toutes les conséquences qu'on peut en
attendre sur le plan stricto sensu
économique or ce qu'on voit c'est
précisément qu'à partir du moment où les
banques centrales ont sorti on peut
parler de l'artillerie guerre finalement
avec des tombereaux de liquidités et
c'est tout ce que énuméré également
olivier des rachats de tout on voit
qu'il ya plus de frontières est ce qu'on
voit très bien c'est que au moindre
risque un risque un peu significatif
alors il ya la réponse des politiques
but de monnet terme donc finalement les
investisseurs ont repris du risque
est-ce que ça suffira pour relancer
véritablement la machine de manière
durable
j'en doute parce que les conséquences
économiques de la période que nous
traversons sont extrêmement négative et
que derrière cette ce regain d'optimisme
des marchés parce qu'on parle même pas
des investisseurs en réalité les
investisseurs dans la plupart des cas
sont pas véritablement
mist mais voilà on a des algorithmes qui
fonctionne bien pour l'instant et et
donc il ya véritablement eu une
respiration à récupérer à peu près la
moitié notamment sur marché américain
des pertes d'intérieur en quelques trois
semaines
donc oui c'est cette politique a eu un
effet sur les marchés est-ce qu'elle a
un effet sur l'économie
on peut considérer que si les marchés se
arrête de baisser c'est déjà un élément
négatif en moins probablement il n'en
reste pas moins qu on est face à une
situation dans laquelle c'est cette
politique est clairement insuffisante et
où on peut pas escompter que les seules
actions monétaires puisse permettre de
préparer un avenir un peu plus plus
radieux et surtout avec plus de
croissance pour sortir de cette crise ça
y est après plusieurs mois d'absence le
tiroir cachée de retour cette semaine
nous parle du plan à 750 milliards
présenté fin mai par la présidente de la
commission européenne
ursula von der leyen baptisé avec un nom
bien cool next generation eeyou c'est le
plus ambitieux des plans de relance
jamais proposé en europe
750 milliards qui viennent s'ajouter à
la somme rondouillard de 2 540 milliards
déjà mises en place dans l'urgence on va
pas rentrer dans les détails du montage
financier complexe mais en gros l'argent
serait d'emprunter sur les marchés avec
la garantie de l'état et ne devrait être
remboursé qu'à partir de 2028
en gros de la dette quoi les pays les
plus touchés par la pandémie récupérerai
forcément plus comme l'italie avec plus
de 170 milliards ou l'espagne avec plus
de 140 milliards et la france bat 39
milliards un dixième de la somme irait
aux entreprises privées et enfin une
partie du gâteau irait aux systèmes de
santé des pays membres qui ont montré
dirons-nous quelques lacunes ces
derniers mois bref un bon plan de
relance qui montre une belle solidarité
européenne pour tous tous car en europe
quatre pays autriche pays bas danemark
et suède résiste encore et toujours au
plan de relance
après les corps au gabon après le plan
franco allemand
pas sûr qu'ils acceptent celui là lors
du vote mi juin
et si ça bloque quelques mois après le
break site
ce serait encore un coup dur pour lui
c'est pas du tout les nième plan
à mes yeux c'est un plan tout à fait
nouveau je veux pas utiliser des mots un
peu grandiloquent à dire que c'est un
plan historique
j'aime parler comme ça les mots qui ne
disent rien mais c'est vrai que c'est un
plot très original et c'est un plan qui
fait à mes yeux un bond qualitatif pour
l'europe qu'on n'a jamais vus pourquoi
un bond qualitatif c'est justement les
caractéristiques que monsieur de la
marche n'a pas évoqué et cours vous
acceptez riec genre jeu j'ai vu moi-même
tout d'abord pour la première fois on
parle d'une bête commune donc un tabou
est brisé
il y a une dette commune puisque
l'argent sera soulevé c'est à dire sur
les marchés avec la garantie de l'union
européenne sous la gare optique du
budget européen
donc c'est pas les pays chacun pour soi
comme à des motions de la marche
messieurs c'est bien l'union européenne
qui va mettre son sens sur ce programme
deuxièmement deuxième tabou
et il y aura bien des transferts
budgétaires puisque comme vous l'avez
évoqué l'argent ira plus vers les pays
aux plus grandes difficultés
donc le sud de le de l union européenne
pas seulement la grèce d'ailleurs mais
plutôt et principalement l'italie et
l'espagne
donc c'était vrai transferts budgétaires
qui s'opère pour la première fois et
pour briser deuxième thabo troisième
d'amour qui sera brisée
si tout cela se concrétise bien sûr
parce que on parle on ne parle que d'une
proposition de la production 1 à l'état
actuel des choses mais on doit parler de
ce qu'on a sur la table donc troisième
tabou qui sera brisé sa thabo politique
puisque on a des priorités politiques
communes c'est le fameux green new deal
en bon français et l'économie
informatique ou les villes attention
digitales aux meilleurs français
donc ça aussi c'est nouveau au moins
tout cet argent pour faire des réformes
commune pour tout et pas seulement la
zone euro d'ailleurs mais pour toute
l'union européenne et 4e temps je
l'avais un moment parce que un mot parce
qu'il ya la chose la plus importante
4e 4e singularité importante
il y a des ressources propres pour la
première fois dans le budget européen on
parle on les sent un peu de côté le
poids du budget mais on parle pour la
première fois des ressources importantes
propres pour l'union européenne
ressources propres
ça veut dire politique économique
commune et tout ça c'est des nouveautés
très importante à mes yeux
alors avant de revenir assure toutes ces
nouveautés oublié je voudrais vous faire
réagir sur ce principe de deyne de dette
commune le a été a beaucoup critiqué au
début de l'épidémie notamment pour ses
difficultés à parler d'une seule voix
est-ce que là notamment avec ce principe
de mutualisation des dettes sans message
d'unité que je souhaite aussi passé et
le lait chier ils peuvent passer tous
les messages qu'ils veulent
vous avez comme le feu comme vient de le
dire notre invité c'est un projet et
vous avez des gens qui sont vent debout
contre ce projet ce qui est assez
logique
vous vous allez financer comment cette
histoire
vous savez que la dette c'est de l'impôt
futur donc en effet monsieur thierry
breton vient nous expliquer qu'on va
payer des impôts est ce que vous pensez
que vous avez des gens qui dans aux pays
bas ou en france vont vouloir aller
payer des impôts pour pour les grecs ou
pour les italiens pour les espagnols ça
ne marche pas ça ne fonctionne pas c'est
encore une tentative désespérée d'avoir
une europe fédérale et s'enfoncer dans
les robes fédérale alors qu'on sait que
l'europe est morte
enfin un acte et qu'elle est morte
et le premier qui devrait en être
heureux c'est notre invité qui y est je
pense que la grèce a assez et à ses
sphères de leurs deux on ne pas vouloir
continuer je crois en tout ont noté que
monsieur de la maxe exagère aussi sur la
résistance qu'il y aura sur ce plan les
fameux 4 frugaux les quatre pays qui
rechigne dit tu en as a payé de l'année
leur réaction officielle tout du moins a
été prudente mais positive ces quatre
pays auquel vous faites référence et
l'autriche les pays bas la suède et le
danemark est ce qu'ils ont réellement
les moyens de s'y opposer
oui ton pays à moyens de s'opposer plus
qu' on doit trouver un consensus à la à
la fin du jour mais ce que j'étais en
train de dire c'est que la façon dont
l'europe aux graisses et pour une fois
le mot est réelle il ya un progrès
tangible la façon donc dans l'europe
grèce c'est à travers des négociations
c'est un travers le mot n'est pas un
roman des compromis donc y aura
forcément un compromis il y aura un
compromis génération y moi j'aime le
gaza personne ne sait aujourd'hui si
ceux-ci ce projet sera votée ou pas vous
savez que c'est l'unanimité que si vous
avez deux ou trois pays qui refusent cet
accord le cet accord ne sera pas ne sera
pas mis en place donc voilà après je je
je ne je ne fais pas de plans sur la
comète
aujourd'hui on n'en sait rien on verra
bien mais de toute façon
rassurez vous si ce plan là ne sort pas
au niveau de l'europe
vous aurez monsieur m'a conquis vous
annoncera que ils s'endettent tout seul
de 50 100 200 milliards de plus c'est
pas grave de toute façon c'est au final
c'est nous qui payons donc et
malheureusement on paiera de plus en
plus